dis donc moi président
direction le sud pour notre moi
président entourent la question reste la
même et si vous oui vous vous étiez
candidat à l'élection présidentielle
qu'auriez vous dit pour convaincre les
électeurs aux anses d'arlet on y
réfléchit très sérieusement question
un peu difficile là qu'est ce que je
vais proposer au président vous
président aider les chômeurs aider les
pauvres
et puis qu'ils aient moins besoin de
plus de travail aux questions si j'étais
prise qu'ils étaient candidats
républicains du président ce serment je
dirais que c'est sûrement ce que je vois
quelle que soit la situation soit
changer l'un ce moment là et si la
question peut paraître difficile pour
certains pour d'autres
la réponse ne se fait pas attendre c'est
quelque chose d'impossible pour moi vous
savez ça très bien donc je ne peux pas
dire que je serai président de la
république
mais si par rapport à la question que
vous me posez la première chose j'ai
essayé d'écouter tout le peuple français
avant et de me préparer en amont pour
savoir ce qui serait bien pour eux et
bien pour tous nos trois pays
voilà voté pour mais il ya aussi les
promesses qu'elle promet ce faire c'est
tellement compliqué maintenant je ne
sais pas je ne sais pas nous avons
maintenant des candidats à qui peut-on
faire confiance
[Musique]
nous quittons les anses d'arlet pour
rivière pilote à l'ombre du marché
couvert les candidats sont nombreux mais
surtout très différent de la marchande
d'accra de daurade de morue d'oursins de
crevettes j'en passe et des meilleurs ça
ne m'intéresse pas en passant par le
joueur de dominos les autres alors si
vous étiez candidat à la présidentielle
qu est ce que vous auriez de mes enfants
à ma femme mes taboulé pour finir par la
marchande de fruits et légumes il est
clair que tout le monde ici a son mot à
dire
le niveau est trop pour moi c'est non
voilà c'est dit prochaine étape de notre
tour des communes à la recherche de
réponse à notre question trinité robert
face à la mer on a tant de choses à dire
moi présidente mois président
[Musique]